[Music]
remember when uh seven percent of tea
party protests turned violent
i was like what percentage was that dude
there was somebody who claimed someone
at a tea party protest said the n-word
and they were never able to offer proof
and that just maligned the entire
movement right for the entire country
listen it's because conservatives keep
playing
let me tell you something if you were
playing monopoly
and and then the the person you're
playing against kept cheating
would you you wouldn't keep playing no
you'd be like okay i'm not going to play
this game if for some reason
conservatives and even to an extent
moderates who the ones who are getting
more politically active
are sitting here as the media will say
something like
oh you know this group of people did a
bad thing and then all these
conservatives go oh that's not fair you
can't say this about us
and then the left will do something and
the right will go hey look at the left
and the left
not playing that's a really not playing
that's a really good point yeah the
republicans are like please please don't
view me as a racist don't view me as a
sexist whatever it is you're labeling me
instead of just saying it's ridiculous
sometimes the media
instead of the republican party saying
you know don't give
interviews to like a certain
organization
like just straight up i don't do
interviews
i don't blame you i won't do it i get an
email i'm like gutter
gone don't care these people are not
look
it is not the job of a journalist to
tell you the truth it is the
or the modern journalist it's the job of
a modern journalist to generate traffic
for the website yes that the marketing
that the sales team can pitch then to a
brand and say
look how many clicks we got so let me
tell you what what do you think happens
then
if uh i don't know people are out
throwing cans of goya beans
at a riot goya is going to be like we
don't want to be associated with this
so so don't include we're going to stop
some i've seen it happen
i've seen it happen where big brands
will be like hey you're reporting on
this story
man you know they do it's a really
clever tactic
when some companies know they're about
to get some a whistleblower
and they know where it's coming from so
a journalist could be like hi
you know we're calling you know the tim
poole show
we've got a whistleblower who's going to
say these things about you
then then the big company when they hear
this they go oh
you know it's so unfortunate you're
going to do the story we were about to
do a big
ad buy with you yeah
you know so so like basically you know
you'll get a cookie company
someone will say they're putting rat
poison in their cookies the journalist
calls the cookie company
then the cookie company says let me get
back to you and we'll give you a quote
calls the sales department to the news
organization and says we'd like to buy a
million dollar ad buy with you
and they go oh hot dog done so bribery
and then
so it's it's it's circuitous but yes
because then the ad team goes
hey everybody just a heads up we're
doing a big ad with cookie company so
it's a conflict of interest any of the
reporting we do just just so you know
now most the editorial teams are
independent for a lot of these companies
so it doesn't work that way but a lot of
a lot of the new companies don't have
that same level of independence and will
absolutely be like yo shut that story
down man they're giving us money
a lot of new media has no oversight at
all it's like no fact check a guy
running a website and he links to
another article that he read which links
to a third article which links back to
his article and that's the
oh that's why we have snopes thank
goodness let me tell you
so i had nbc smear me claiming that i
was pushing the seth rich conspiracy
theory
which is completely bunk it was based
off of a live stream from several years
ago when a fox
business article came out claiming seth
rich had information on his computer
they retracted the story
when the story came out i was like whoa
this is crazy
and i made a point about how if i were
if someone asked me if it was real i'd
be like
you know 65 70 or something i think i
said like 57 to 65 percent
what i was saying was even though this
story came out claiming
that he had the information i still
don't believe it what did they do
several years later and well after the
article got retracted
nbc news puts in their article that i
pushed it and they linked to some random
conspiracy blog
then variety and a bunch of other
outlets cloned that article without fact
checking
and then nbc removed it and they created
a big circle of self-citation
it's called xkcd you know for all his
faults
he calls this uh essentially a is a
different version i'll explain it
cytogenesis like sight in genesis
and he's uh he describes a phenomenon
that happens on wikipedia this is
amazing
someone will go on wikipedia and they'll
write up something nonsensical
they'll say you know uh freedom tunes is
a
far left cartoon show which is true
and then they'll publish it right and if
if you're not talking about trump you're
talking about someone who isn't the most
prominent person in the world
it'll probably get overlooked for a
short amount of time but then a
journalist
will be like i need to find information
on freedom tunes and they'll
look it up on wikipedia and say it's a
left-wing cartoon then they'll write a
story
based on some glance they glanced on
wikipedia and saying freedom tunes comma
a left-wing cartoon
then someone on wikipedia says hey
there's no citation for this and they go
got it right here and then they take
that other article so it's a circle of
fake sources
yeah this is like laundering have you
heard the phrase idea laundering i can't
remember was that
one of the weinsteins or gad sad i can't
remember who it originates
yeah it's basically the same concept i
got accused of that because some
anarchists on reddit posted something
like make sure you bring your guns or
something
to uh to a portland you know to a
protest with proud boys
and so i tweeted they're talking about
bringing guns and then a bunch of
conservatives picked it up and then it
started the game of telephone
and then it became antifa announces
they're getting armed for you know
armed anti-fun picked up steam in like
2010. something about being able to make
ad revenue online
about 2010 is when it started to pick up
steam like youtube really
pioneered internet ad revenue yeah and
then you could start your own website
you get google
ads facebook ads started paying you and
it was facebook
facebook because facebook was like the
beginning of this algorithmic content
drive
so what happened was you had uh
in the early days of facebook somebody
makes a news website and they would call
it like
you know freedom tunes news oh my
goodness i'm so on the spot here
and so uh i mean i'm just i'm just it's
it's a safe reference your brand
so let's say you have two two channels
tim cast and freedom tunes news
and freedom tunes news is an opinionated
hard you know
just horrible just like trump i hate
obama
that obama and then tim cass is very
much like today obama announced a new
plan to bring peace to the middle east
and you know of course well not really
obama
you know obama's new plan was to bring
drone bombs to the middle east did
announce it i think
the point is in the early days of
facebook
and it's even true to this day in a lot
of ways on many many platforms people
don't interact with boring straight news
yeah and they they choose the more
bombastic content i mean this is true
for me too because i
do opinion you know i fact check but my
i i like to think that my
my opinions are to a certain degree uh
informed but of course my you know i
could be wrong their opinions
and so people are more interested in
seeing what someone has to say now
there's a couple things to consider here
we don't need straight facts like
straight fact news because
we know for the most part the moment
something happens donald trump
gives a speech and he says you know i'm
going to
win a nobel peace prize i was nominated
and we all know we all know
okay and then a news story comes out
saying donald trump wins the nobel you
know is nominated for a peace prize and
we say i heard it already trump tweeted
it
i don't need this article so the article
that does get clicked is
here's why trump should win a peace
prize that's a good point and then
people want to hear the argument
but back in the day what happened was
these news brands
you had straight news and you had
bombastic news and because people
weren't clicking straight news bombastic
news was gaining way more traffic
then the venture capital came in and
they said hey you're getting a million
views
these guys are only getting a hundred
thousand here's a million dollars to
keep going
and then they took a million dollars
hired more people just like them and
they created an
empire out of bombastic hyper-partisan
content but here's the best part
these companies started doing a b
testing figuring out which which which
articles work and which articles didn't
and so what happens is keywords in the
algorithm
if you have on facebook some an article
says please brutality
it'll get x views if you have
racism you'll get y views but racist
police brutality combines them for x
plus y views
or maybe even x times y depending so you
got so the more you stuff into the
article the more reach you get
and that that created so in my opinion
this resulted in the rise of
a psychotic fringe mainstream left
because they keep running in circles
like chasing each other with more and
more extreme narratives
and the the the moderates and the right
like even old-school liberals
aren't that aren't in this game they're
they're they're trying
they're doing more research on their own
and they're not trusting the mainstream
media
the left blindly trusts these brands
without question i can speak 100
first person i was in that at mines bill
and i were writing articles
and we were writing spectacular
headlines we were trying to get clicks
and we were part of a group of news
organizations that were coming up 2010
on facebook
that a lot of people you know um and we
were just
putting it out there but now we would
notice violence would get a lot of
clicks so there'd be this temptation to
write these articles about violence
and the day the boston bombing happened
i realized i'm not going to go that
route good for
you when i write articles about it we
get tons of traffic but it perpetuates
the violence
so i stopped i don't know do you think
it perpetuates the violence yeah
definitely i died i saw it firsthand i
think
you might be conflating a bit more so
telling people
a a violent terror act happened could
result in a backlash where people call
for law and order to stop
violence but the people that are over
reaction the people that are making
money off of that happening
subconsciously want it to keep happening
but that's not going to that's
that's not going to make violence so
here's what happens it makes people
write articles about
the the police so it depends on which
way you go if you read an article about
the boston bombing it's going to result
in security
it's going to result in people having an
overreaction to
terrorism and they're going to demand
the state secure them and keep them safe
if you write about police brutality
meaning the threat comes from the state
you're going to get waves of people
demanding the you know the dismantling
of the state
and that's what's happening now so
because you have conservatives and even
to a certain degree moderates
who hold all moral foundations loyalty
purity authority being
the three according to jonathan heights
research that the left doesn't have
they're the ones saying well wait a
minute i'm actually i'm not just going
to throw the police department out you
know i have loyalty
i i respect to a certain degree
authority although conservatives also do
have a large libertarian uh liberty
spectrum a moral foundation as well so
here's what happens
you get the liberals according to
jonathan heights research have care and
fairness as their moral foundations
and the right has all six which is uh
care fairness authority purity loyalty
and liberty
that means if you come to me and say all
cops are bad you're going to trigger
loyalty respect for authority and
uh and right then it's going to it's
going to make it so the conservatives go
whoa
whoa whoa whoa all of them i'm loyal to
the people who have served my community
and helped me to the military
things like that the left doesn't have
those therefore when they see
police brutality they go oh rebel rebel
rebel and they say burn it all down
destroy it
and that's literally what's happening so
what i think we see is
you have conservatives who have a strong
basis in
all moral foundations and again this is
not i mean it's jonathan heights
research
it's the uh he's got a book it's called
what was it called the coding of the
american mind yeah definitely gotta read
this stuff
and and and if i'm getting it wrong then
jonathan can absolutely correct me and
you guys can come at me my general
understanding is
or at least i should say my
interpretation would be if
we see a story as uh so i i have a
decent
balance i'm like uh left left liberal in
the moral foundations
even leaning a bit conservative because
of like authority and purity
and i have a big liberty uh foundation
because you can actually take the test
where they they map you out oh
fascinating
yeah so so if you come to me with this
extremist article that says
something like the boston bombing tear
around every corner
my liberty foundation is gonna start
flaring red red alert red alert red
alert and i'm gonna be like whoa whoa
whoa whoa i respect liberty
i have a strong liberty moral foundation
so i'm not going to give up my freedoms
just because we saw this
you know this this article my authority
will also be like yeah but yeah but so
you end up with this like moderate
approach
okay okay so we need some security we
got to respect that we need police and
we need some way to stop these
terrorists
but we ought to make sure we don't cross
the line and we respect civil liberties
even for people who want to protest the
left doesn't have authority
or a large liberty it's mostly just care
and fairness so when they see a video of
police brutality they go
burn the system down the police are
crooked there's nothing to stop them
they have no respect they have no
loyalty they have no purity they have no
they have
very little liberty libertarians my
favorite it's all liberty
they have like very little of anything
but liberty straight to the roof
so it's like some of these there's
there's like the question the ques the
test for the moral foundations has some
really gross stuff
that i'm not even gonna say and uh
libertarians are like
don't care you can do what you want so
long as you're not hurting somebody else
it's consensual oof
right right you see where i'm going like
yeah when i was writing
but that's oh well now to be fair too i
mean obviously i haven't taken a look at
that test i know that like i'm not as
libertarian as i used to be but a lot of
libertarians probably would say like i
disapprove of this thing
but i don't want the government to be
involved but i guess i'm not sure to the
extent to which you're speaking and you
didn't want to say them i assume it's
stuff that would get us demonetized
uh i'll tell you one of them was
creating a an adult
love-making doll based on your niece oh
that's disgusting yeah you should go to
jail i mean you should be shot if you do
that so
so so the issue is conservatives and
anyone actually there are people who
actually said yes to that absolutely
oh conservatives have a purity
foundation where they see that and they
go oh
like the reaction you just had yeah yeah
people who are just libertarian don't
have strong foundations
and i'm not trying to drag other
libertarians because you can be
libertarian and still have strong
foundations
it's a generality that libertarians
basically say hey man
if you want to do your thing in private
in your own home
then why am i going to stop you from
doing as long as you're not hurting
anybody else
okay so i think when i was writing these
articles and other people were writing
these articles about the boston bombing
and other violent
things that would happen i think it was
inciting the left and i didn't know what
the left was
why why why why because when i would
write an article about a terror
act it would spark fear in the comments
thousands of people would freak out and
then i'd see other articles start to be
written about the same thing and people
would be afraid in those comments and
then my boss would
want more of that because it was
catching and then i would try and write
about solar panels
and it would get a thousandth of the
views but people would be talking about
how awesome this new technology was
and i had a choice because i don't have
so much time in my life of what to
propagate and the media is doing that
now with it
it's twitter so it started with facebook
created
or i should say it facebook created a
magnifying
like lens or like a canon to propel
critical race theory
because it fit the algorithm so
perfectly to say like the intersection
of all of these different ridiculous
ideas
now it's twitter twitter has gamified
hate and
rage that's fine and so so so that's why
i you know i was thinking about this
earlier i talked about it i wonder if
jenker of the young trucks has always
been such a really mean person no
no i don't think so why is he so mean
now i don't know him as a person
he's frustrated yeah so i i remember the
last time i saw the
uh so a couple uh a couple several years
ago i saw him at at uh
vidcon and he walked up to me and he
shook my head said how's things been
going i'm like
pretty good and he was like right now
right now i'm like how are you like yeah
it's going pretty good
we talked for a little bit he's like hey
man i'll see you around take care the
next time i saw him he snapped starts
screaming at me he's just like a
like a like and and now him and the
young turks are mocking my appearance
like insulting my looks it's the
weirdest thing
i don't understand why they've become so
uh personally
and directly nasty so do you i don't i'm
not even trying to insult them
at all i wish i'm the best i don't get
it do you think they've changed or that
you're just viewed as a boogie man by
the left now and so they're jumping on
board they changed
so they were less angry towards their
opponents at this time not necessarily
but
twitter's giving them a vehicle to just
be angry all the time well
that's the funny thing about twitter
right like on on a good day
on twitter or a day on twitter where
you're successful it's usually because
you have said something
that's really upset somebody else and on
a bad day it's something has been said
that upsets you so it's kind of a play
stupid games when stupid prizes type
but you know a lot of the tweets that
i'll put up like my reaction to crazy
news like there was a story and it said
something like um
pennsylvania is is saying that if the
signature doesn't match in a mail-in
vote
the vote can't be disqualified so i
quote tweet that and put lol
yeah i didn't say oh the end oh they're
evil i just put
lol because my view on things is very
much like i remember this you see galaxy
quest
no is that is that the uh the star trek
parody with tim allen
yeah i've never seen it you had familiar
so i'm reminded of the scene where tony
shalhoub
he's in engineering and the aliens are
all around him and they're like in an
emergency and like
they're about to die and they ask him
and he's just laughing he's like it's
going good i guess and he's just having
a good time and i'm like that's the kind
of attitude i think would benefit people
like look man if you can't control
anything don't scream and freak out
enjoy life find the best of it have a
laugh
i'm watching all this craziness happen
around me i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna get angry about it you
know sometimes completely
like you and him are in similar but very
different situations because he has a
huge company now i don't know the size
of how many employees they have
and i heard that they were losing money
at one point he like
i guess he threatened to uh like he i
guess he did fire somebody who wanted to
form a union or something like that yeah
yeah
he wouldn't didn't want his people to
unionize so so that's a different that
must be extremely stressful just from a
personal perspective on chang
um anna doesn't seem to be going through
that stress yeah i mean i
i can't speak to anything particularly
about the young turks but you said
something really interesting sort of
about stress levels and how you react to
a high stakes situation
and i find that in our culture we have
yet to find this happy medium or at
least most people have
where you have legitimate moral concerns
and you're trying to make the world a
better place
but you're not so caught up in whether
you as an individual will be perfectly
successful at that
it seems as if people are just
completely nihilistic and everything's
funny and they don't care about anything
and they're just going to do whatever
they want to have a good time
and why get caught up in any of the
morality of it because it's just going
to stress me out and then there are
other people who do have legitimate
moral concerns but then they go over the
top thinking that they're the person who
needs to solve every single problem
and they lose their minds when they're
not successful and i find that the best
way to go about it and this is something
i struggle with as well because i don't
know that i've got that perfect balance
yet but
it's to follow your moral code to do as
best as you possibly can but to
recognize that god has a plan and if
you're not successful things will be as
they should
i think i think i know where my bias in
this regard comes from like why am i
talking about the young turks and not
say like turning point or like some
other conservative group
well i don't think they actually do it
all they're all that bad like candace
owens has certainly
had negative words for like say i think
cardi b was that was that they were they
remember
each other that was a whole huge thing
it was it was a huge thing and they were
both throwing [ __ ] at each other
but i i started thinking about it just
now twitter has banned all of the right
that's been
you know bombastic controlly and nasty
so very true
and not even not even people who are
nasty i'm saying like trolley as well
like hashtag learn to code
the left literally uh incites violence
and organizes violent riots
on twitter and they just do it with
impunity no one's going to stop them
so what ends up happening is there is
there is little incentive on the right
for people to become that rage monster
because you will be banned
like that and so conservatives are very
wary of this
right wing individuals are like you know
i'm not gonna you know i don't wanna get
banned i say the wrong thing
and then they people get banned all the
time yeah the left
with impunity are incentivized to be
rageful and hateful and
mean and i'm just sitting here like
you'd be very much you'd be much more
successful appealing
and you'd convince more people if you
were nice about it
yeah that's for sure but they don't want
to or you could just make fun of them in
cartoons or you could just own the libs
in cartoons i don't
think that helps i think you know that's
one strategy it works really well
cartoons are actually awesome i
appreciate that but when you get
powerful
the nicer you are that's the more you're
successful you'll be the more people
will like you yeah and to be fair no i
do try to keep it lighthearted and i
think i make it obvious that i'm like
i'm like just joking around and playing
around
but i hear what you're saying and one
thing i've noticed along with this
is it seems as if we're playing
basically what you said by two different
sets of rules
and when you're in public life the
further to the right you get the higher
your difficulty setting becomes
so you see this right wing figures tend
to have to be much more careful about
what they say because each little thing
can be taken out of context and their
life can be destroyed
donald trump oh except for donald trump
he has the cheat code
donald trump's a 99 overall and he
represents the right so all these people
on the left
that are like 12 overall 13 overall
they're letting them be angry
like say it's a weight gain a game of
weight donald trump exudes a thousand
points of weight all these other people
like
i don't want to drag change he's awesome
but like people like anyone on the left
that gets angry on twitter
and posts like uh f this uh this
horrible they have weight of like 12 or
13 so twitter's letting them add their
weight up collectively
so that they can equal out to donald
trump that's ridiculous i know it is
ridiculous but that's i think what
happened is what's happening i think
they're just biased and they're and
they're all laughing they're together
and the twitter employees are like
orangeman is bad i like that tweet how
dare you tell me to learn to code you're
banned forever yeah exactly
by the way lydia i think you're about to
say something ian made a point earlier
about how being nice will get you
further in life and this is something
that i hold on to
i actually don't know if it's true
because i don't know how far i've gotten
in life i love my life but
i do think that the old adage that
people don't
know people don't care how much you know
until they know how much you care is 100
true and i think there is also some
truth it was interesting what you said
sheamus about donald trump having this
cheat code which is don't care
i was like that's kind of interesting
because i think the right care is way
too much about being called
racist and i i appreciate that they care
about their reputation
that's very meaningful to them but at
the same time it's like maybe you
care a little too much maybe you would
benefit from having a little don't care
in your life i don't know
exactly well i find that the right wing
actually tends to worship at the altar
of human respect it's all about ensuring
everybody knows that i'm a good person
it's the
thing the left says about me aren't true
but i think moral foundations
i think that could be part of it but at
the same time maybe it's just
a quirk of the fact that we live in this
system where the left doesn't seem to
pay a price for being far left but
they don't care what you think of their
political views and we
seem to and that has to stop if we're
ever gonna win what happens when you're
loyal to someone who is not loyal to you
you get burned and that's exactly what
we have conservatives with a loyalty
moral foundation loyal to the citizens
of this country
and a left that is not loyal in return
they just believe in this
nebulous concept of fairness and
whatever that means
but they don't care about you or what
you've done for them
and that's why they don't care for the
police they have no loyalty to the
system as it stands that's helped them
succeed they view america's inherently
evil and i'm not saying literally every
single one of them but the dominant
very vocal ones view america as
inherently evil
they do they say it's colonization and
it's white supremacy
and they accuse the founding fathers of
these atrocities and they ignore all of
the really great things that have been
done
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you